hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday April 3rd 2023
um what's going on and how are you I'll
tell you what's going on with me I
forgot today was Monday
I was literally
on the plane on an airplane
uh coyote [__] is in heat I was on the
plane and I [__] said wait a minute
I gotta do a part what the [__] today's
Monday oh Jesus you know what happened
was I did two shows last night
so that made it feel like it was
Saturday night in my head it was
Saturday night
but to everybody else it was Sunday
night and you guys all agreed so today's
today is in fact Monday
so my apologies for being late
um I'm not going to apologize for what I
did last night on stage for two shows in
Ottawa which was [__] murder
talking [__] here
um no I had good shows I felt really
good about it it was the perfect amount
of silly
uh that I that I that I needed
um and the crowds were [__] amazing
I was up there in Ottawa right I flew in
Friday because I was going to the Ottawa
Senators versus the Toronto Maple Leafs
on Saturday night
and uh like I mentioned before I've been
trying to go to a game up there forever
I was supposed to go with the buddy of
mine 11 years ago
and unfortunately a friend of mine
passed away I had to go to the funeral
um
[Music]
so that got put on hold and uh then
years went by I tried again and
something else [__] came up
Otto I could just never
you know I was joking with them when I
went on stage you know I said hey you
know it's nice to be in this city
everybody skips
because everybody does Montreal
then everybody goes over to Toronto
hoping they're going to run into Drake
at a rap Raptors game right
and then they can [__] you know
do that whole thing whatever whatever
that world is
that I've never been in
you know
I was thinking about that you know
somebody was talking about some [__]
that used to happen at The Comedy Store
I'm like that never happened man that
used to happen
I was like where the [__] was I I was
there
Oh Billy introvert you know served me
well though
it has served me well I just go in I do
my shows I talk to myself before and
after I'm on stage questioning
everything that I do and then I get back
in my car and I leave it served me well
you know
like that guy that collects the numbers
for the mafia back in the day and just
minded his own [__] business
he walked over he got the package he
went over gave it to the other guy they
gave him the thing they doesn't know
anybody's name he doesn't look at
anybody that's that's just what he does
it was this little Cog and a bigger
wheel
that's how I've lived my life I have
never been the um
The After Party Guy it was you know even
from when I was young it was too [__]
loud and I was too orange to be there
I mean honestly picture me
in VIP at a nightclub with a full head
of reddish orange hair I mean you know
fit as a rail
questioning everything that I've done in
the previous five seconds just imagine
that vibe
in a club in a nightclub it just yeah I
was never that guy I was more the uh sad
Sac dive bar
let's go drink with some [__]
retired Merchant Marines for some reason
I I always felt more comfortable there
which
um
is uh you know
it's not really a choice it's just sort
of how you're made up and I would have
been the guy
in the nightclub if a bunch of other
[__] didn't happen to me but if that
other [__] didn't happen me I wouldn't
have been a comedian so that's the
trade-off
right
did that land did I land on my feet on
that one I can't really type but I was
always like [__]
after the shows where do you want to go
where there's as little people as
possible
unless it was a sporting event
I'm in a [__] hotel room right now
and there's a picture of somebody's
[__] baby like what is what is
there's all of these books here
I'm gonna do what's his face uh who's
goddamn white baby is that
Cal Williams it's one of my favorite
clips of a movie ever
um that is [__] creepy
all right
there's a book here called domestic
violence
oh almost a dangerous was almost
dangerous three Great American poets
Whitman Dickinson and frost all right
well I can tell you right now if I had
to choose between the two I'm going with
domestic violets
[__] place is weird
why would you have a picture of a
[__] baby up there that is so goddamn
creepy
you know what this feels like
this feels like one of those [__]
apartments that Jewish people had like
hidden you know that's what this [__]
place feels like when you know when they
do those [__] creepy things about
Nazis
and then people that hit Jewish people
during all of that time and and these
[__] heartless bastards [__]
coming in trying to find people that's
what that feels I don't know why because
it's a black and white photo and it's
like who the [__] has a book of Walt
Whitman
you know sure maybe you have it on your
Kindle
somebody asked me that today you know
because I'm reading this incredible book
and which I can't name yet because it's
not out yet holy [__] there's a woman in
the window across the [__] way what
are we doing here in a dirty window
you know is it bad if I assume she's a
dirty woman
she's a man she's a woman of the streets
um I'm reading this incredible book
right and
another buddy of mine happens to be
reading a book
wait do I got a [__] balcony outside
window you know these things aren't
going to open up
you know it's a [__] worse this
goddamn suicide jumpers
because they jump none of the windows
open up far enough right they don't open
up far enough you can't [__] get any
goddamn air in here
you know
and then what if there's a fire
and I actually do need to [__] take a
chance and jump I can't do it anymore
if the word I know what the [__] it
happened shut up
these stupid fire codes you know the
firemen either are you
um
if you are you're sitting in front of
your Firehouse right now [__] smoking
a cigar looking at the [__] ladies
walking by right and all the old timers
are going you know back in the day we
used to be able to harass them
you know not anymore
it's all this woke [__] you gotta
respect women
rolls his eyes then goes back in the
firehouse and stirs some chili
um
anyway so book what was I talking about
yo he asked me he goes can I send you he
goes uh he goes are you a book guy are
you a Kindle guy I said I'm a book guy I
go I don't understand the Kindle
I've never understood the Kindle
you know it's like uh
why do I
like a book is fine
it just works
and it doesn't become obsolete where
Kindle I imagine at some point I gotta
get the new version and then I can't
handle the speed of the new download of
the [__] book I always view to Kindle
like it's like having like a uh was that
what I say to my buddy was like having
like a [__]
a tablet for like a napkin holder it was
just completely like unnecessary like
this this works
this [__] it's like the [__]
elevators
look at me just bitching about nothing
the [__] elevators right that you
know those ones you go in those
buildings and they try to figure it out
if you go in on the even floors you push
this one and that it down and then it
tries to let you know what elevator is
coming and you got to do all of this
[__] math
it's like can I just press up or down
have the [__] thing show up
and then I'll just stand at the back of
the elevator looking up at the ceiling
can I just do that can I just [__] do
that
um
anyway so I went into Ottawa
flew in there connected through Toronto
and uh I gotta tell you something man
they're the [__] the technology
is incredible when in aviation like when
we landed in Toronto it looked like the
ceiling was at like [__]
50 feet I was like
I mean we landed at night it's like I
don't see anything I don't see anything
and then I just saw the runway
dead center
it's like wow amazing and then we flew
into Ottawa sort of the same thing not
quite as bad
um
so anyway I [__] land and one of the
best things about
Ottawa is they have this canal that they
freeze
you know it's one of the low-key like
greatest things you could ever probably
like bring your family to that like
nobody knows about well maybe not one of
the great it's one of the great things
that I've seen you can skate along this
canal you freaked out at first
especially if you watched The Omen and
you think you're going to go under the
ice and everyone's going to be trying to
save you and they they can't and
there'll be a raven laughing at you
whatever the [__] right
um
but I was talking about this in the last
podcast it's only like I mean I think
like two feet deep at the the deepest
place right
um
but still if you hit your head right you
know there's always some old person
saying that
long time ago there was a guy you know
he fell on his ass and he he went
through like you know when you tuck in a
pocket square
into your suit
jacket you know he went he went in like
that asked first like [__] breach
birth
you know
he [__] is that preach birth I always
forget how that is
it's like those things that hang from
the caves or come up from the floor I
could never remember that
concave convex whatever
asked first and he went he went right in
like a [__] pocket square
and right before he went under he banged
the back of his head and he went
underneath and then the current was just
at the right speed
and the ice was just thick enough
he's still down there today you know
the old people do that now like when I
was a kid that's what old people used to
do they used to scare the [__] [__]
out of you just telling you stories of
horrible things that happen to people
My grandmother used to do that
she really she should just she's just
sit down on the couch and just tell
horror stories
remember she said like one time there
was a guy and and and you know he was
coming to a stoplight and he didn't see
it and he stomped on the brakes he
stopped on the brakes so hard that his
leg went up into his body for the rest
rest of his life he like waddled around
because his legs were uneven
and I was like really and she was like
yeah
[Laughter]
I shouldn't be telling you guys this
[__] that I went up to my mother right
anyway hey Mom Little Billy Little Billy
[__] four years old it's like hey Mom
do you know one time there was a guy he
tried to stop and stop trying his
[__] leg went all the way up I didn't
say [__] his leg went all the way up on
his body
and it stayed like that and she just
looked at me she goes who told you that
and I said Grandma did she goes you
don't listen to her don't listen
[Laughter]
that was the first time I learned
that adults
weren't like you know
sane
I'm not saying not all adults was it my
the first time I realized I just you
know when you're a little kid you just
think adults know everything and what
they say is true and that's the first
time I was the I never forgot that that
was the first time
somebody was telling me that another
adult was full of [__] and I was and
just the concept of that like blew my
little four-year-old mind like wow
adults lie
you know
and then of course the 800 pound gorilla
in the room
was the Santa Claus
Fiasco which never bothered me that
never bothered me
my older brother told me
he found out and then he just [__]
told me and he was upset by it he felt
betrayed
like it's what you guys are just [__]
lying to me like he was old enough to
understand
I wasn't I was still young enough like I
found out there was no Santa Claus at
like six
so I didn't buy into it like I don't
really even have any like recollection I
think really of believing in him no I
would have believed in him by then
but it was only for like a couple of
years like you ever like listen to a
band
and you're like just yeah man this
[__] band you like totally you can't
get enough of them and then you just ah
they just fade away
and then years later the song comes on
you're like oh my God
I said love what the [__] ever happened
to this man you're like oh they've been
putting this been putting out an album
like every year really yeah they still
tour they're still wow
I had no idea
they're still to get all the original
members
that's like what Santa Claus was for me
a couple two three years
I actually have a picture of me sitting
on Santa's lap wearing an O.J Simpson
Buffalo Bills Jersey
[Laughter]
it's my favorite [__] shirt I had
it was the juice man
it's [__] Unstoppable
2 000 yards in a 14 game season
um
anyway so I am here and oh I didn't even
talk about the rest of Ottawa so then we
went to uh the Ottawa Senators Maple
Leafs game I finally get there
the Senators rolled out the red carpet
you know I bought tickets and somehow I
think I mentioned on the podcast someone
from the team heard I was coming and
they said hey you know
you want to trade those tickets out you
can sit in the owner's box I was like uh
you know what yeah I think I would I
usually don't do the box I usually don't
like sitting in the box but there was
something about like I was coming off
three months
of sitting on my ass
being at home and this is my first road
gig
and I was a little sad you know leaving
my fab was sad not a little sad I was
sad leaving my family and I was just
like yeah man
uh I mean maybe I'll just sit in the
[__] box you know
and I went there and it was it was the
best
um
um what do you ever called Luxury Box I
ever sat in because there was no buffer
between you and the regular fans they
just build this little like three foot
wall that anybody could just step over
in fact I was sitting there it was like
I was on display and people coming by
like hey Billy red tits
[__] are you doing here I'm like I got a
show tomorrow night it's all right if I
get a picture
and I think all right and just walk over
no politician nothing you're just
sitting there like you ever see those
those really sad backyards of English
homes those brick [__] ones right
next to each other and all those people
with their [__] hideous teeth you
know there's always some guy with a
green thumb [__] growing lilacs and
potatoes for everybody it would look
like that
but it was wasn't depressing there
wasn't a bad seat in the house
the place can hold standing room like 20
000 people like I can't imagine that
venue
uh in a playoff game so uh Ottawa was
playing Toronto and I'm so out of the
loop with everything now that I got the
kiddos the greatest thing that ever
happened to me other than meet my wife
that gave me the kids
um
I mean I helped out a little bit right I
mean I got the engine started there if
you know what I mean
um
anyway so I guess it's the uh
what the [__] is with this couch
this whole [__] place I swear you
know I feel I feel like I'm on the
Titanic right now we're about ready to
hit an iceberg this was like a a [__]
the the HMS [__] Titanic Suite you
know I remember from that movie The
Leonardo DiCaprio one and there was
those two old people just like
like snuggling with each other
which I think was the right move
you know
they knew they were gonna drown
[Applause]
you might as well do it in a bed holding
on to each other
you know that didn't happen
somebody forgot their teeth and the
other person after [__] 60 years of
marriage was like [__] you I mean the
the the will
to survive like I would say this
uh uh an old married couple like if it
was to save their kid they put their
life on the line but at the end of the
day to save each other they they would
you know that's a 50 50.
you know because at the end of the day
you guys are not related
and that's how that works and that's sad
that's a sad story and I'm in a sad
hotel room
so it's kind of like a sleigh bed and
then they have this random like leopard
printed chair here that looks like
[__] you know
something Cher would have
wherever she you know collects herself
in the morning
you know like [__] celebrities always
talk about that they always have a room
for them to just you know get their head
together
laughs
why the [__] if you have the kind of
money to just have a room to get your
head together don't [__] tell people
that
I swear to God it's like what do you
just want people to hate you nobody
wants to know that you have a meditation
room you [__] [__]
that's got to be oh there's a matching
other
that's one of us that's more of a
cheetah over there
I like to think I know my big cats
it's terrible man
what a [__] hotel just skins these
beautiful animals and puts them on a
[__] chair
so some woman of a certain age can still
feel like she's got a little more vavage
is that what's going on here
I don't condone this
I'm just realizing nothing in this room
matches this is like [__]
I feel like I'm in the leftover room
um
I'm just [__] with you it's a nice
hotel
what am I gonna do it's New York City
though you can hear people building
something across the street
no
I would just love to see a bunch of man
bun construction like Millennial guys
sitting on a girder eating [__] lunch
you know looking at their Kindles
um sorry anyway so go to the game
um ate like a [__] King had a great
time I mean literally center ice
best view of a hockey game I've had
since I can ever remember
right oh this [__] guy with the
goddamn Hammer can you stop with the
progress
what is this [__] guy doing I mean
how many hits do you need to hammer the
[__] thing in listen to this [__]
guy
oh that's a machine no it isn't
it's a guy he's got two hammers
thank God
there he goes again
would I be an [__] if I yell down hey
hey
what time are you off
I don't want to [__] listen to that
all day
um
so the game unfortunately uh I think
Otto was like top four players were all
hurt
um and as much as that's a heated
rivalry I think Toronto's whole deal was
like hey let's go in there let's not
piss him off no rough stuff there was
there was barely a hit in the game and
uh Toronto won
three to nothing it was like [__] ton
of maple leaf fans there
ton of them
and um I know like Ottawa is the capital
of Canada for everybody who doesn't live
in Canada so it's like DC where there's
a lot of like transient people or
whatever but like also I know trying to
get a ticket to the Maple Leafs is
[__] impossible
so
they're like well we'll go see him when
they play Ottawa we'll go do the
two-hour [__] drive that's how rabid
their fan base is like I I you know
Maple Leafs fans you there's there's an
argument out there that they're the best
fans in sports considering they have not
won I'm gonna be 55 in June they have
not won in my lifetime
they won the year before I was born oh
the curse of old Billy red tits I came
in and the whole thing shut down they
were neck and neck with the Montreal
Canadiens Canadians had like 15 cups or
something and and the Leafs had 13.
they had so many [__] cups I still
think they're second all time and they
haven't won in 55 years that's how much
they were crushing it right up until
then but anyway you would think after 55
[__] years of not winning it and not
only not winning it
they're like the old Red Sox where back
in the day you remember like Cubs fans
they used to try to make Cubs fans and
Red Sox fans back when we were in our
century-long drought
acting like we were like one in the same
it's like no we're not we're not [__]
one in the same
the Cubs were every year were out of it
by June
they just started the season and [__]
the bed for the most part
we had a couple of teams there in the
80s but for the most part they just
sucked
they just [__] sucked with the Red
Sox oh my God we we invented ways to
lose uh we're up 18 games with 19 games
to go they've lost 19 in a row and it
come to Yankees
it's a one-game playoff
here's a guy five foot nothing can
barely hit it out of the anfield that's
a deep Drive the lamp Fila
um
every [__] way one strike away single
single single single single pass ball
between the legs oh my God
I don't believe it
I mean when you have like Vin Scully
scratching his head all the baseball
that guy's seen
um
yeah we had every goddamn you know
way to [__] lose that's what the
Maple Leafs do they did everything but
have the Babe Ruth of
um hockey and then like sell him
somewhere else because somebody wanted
to put up their version of Hamilton
whatever the [__] we did way back in the
day so um
anyway the yeah the Maple Leafs do that
they were up three goals in a game seven
against the Bruins something like that I
was at that game
three games three goals three goal lead
with like [__] six minutes left all
the Bruins fans leaving and I only hung
around I didn't think we're gonna win I
just hung around to give dirty looks to
the [__] Maple Leaf fans because I
don't like when the fancy other team
take over your stadium so that's the
only reason why I stayed
score Bruins
score Bruins tied up Bruins overtime
score Bergeron go [__] yourself
I mean part of like the NHL playoffs now
is watching Maple Leaf fans standing
that awful footage they show every year
it should come with a warning
of them standing outside their [__]
arena for some reason the game seven
never seems to be in their Arena and
they're just standing outside the arena
there's all this excitement the blue and
white the towels are going everybody's
jumping up and down hugging each other
they're scoring goals they went in
somewhere about three quarters of the
way through the second period the first
[__] skate drops
and then you just see it and the the
energy of the crowd shifts and it gets
sadder and sadder and sadder and then
all of a sudden they're losing and then
people start leaving and then they
always have to at the end after they
blow it and the other team's celebrating
and all their fans of the other team are
going [__] nuts they always cut back
to outside
uh Toronto's [__] Arena and there's
just a couple of stragglers slowly
walking away
on that little Bluff where they stand
it's just
you would think
that that would make them after a while
at the very least not true but you know
Red Sox fans even when they were chant
in 1918 we went everywhere I'm just
saying they're [__] great fans they
really are 100 respect for those sons of
[__]
um why do they gotta be sons of [__]
I don't know because I got intimacy
issues I don't like saying nice things
to people it [__] makes me feel weird
can I do that
um
the canal didn't freeze over though this
year first time in 75 years
I think 76 people told me that when I
was there I also went by to wrap this up
here I went by Dave's Drum Shop
I went online you know trying to like
do something healthy here because I'm in
my 10 days of uh
not uh being a [__] you know
drinking coffee and all of that type of
stuff and smoking cigars and doing being
an idiot
um
so I went up me and me and club soda
Kenny took a walk
from uh I would say like we're over near
Parliament and we walked over this place
Dave's Drum Shop because I went on his
website and I could tell that it was a
uh it was an old school
um
like Drum Shop it just looked like he
had all his [__] and I went in there and
it was it was just this guy had
everything if you're a drummer and
anywhere near Ottawa you got to go to
Dave's Drum Shop
the guy had literally
everything
a zillion drum kits he had drum kits set
up that you could play
uh he had like uh
the DW the anniversary double pedal that
I didn't know was even out carbon fiber
carbon fiber carbon fiber
um he had one of those those
um
V drum electronic kits that looks like a
[__] drum kit
um
Greg soner Ludwig the Vista lights
mallets he had [__] everything a
bunch of symbols it was like two stores
jammed together
drummer heaven
um I hope we made it out to the show we
left them a couple of tickets
um all right
and with that oh by the way I got my
first [__] caffeine headache
from not drinking coffee but I also I
drank coffee like a [__] animal the
last day March 31st listen to this I
made myself a cappuccino
I went to the airport I got a double
espresso it tasted like [__]
so I go you know what let me get a
cappuccino instead I had the Double
Espresso there so I took the Double
Espresso and I poured it in the
cappuccino and then I drank that yes a
quadruple shot cappuccino yes it did
taste like [__] I [__] it up so I
ordered another cappuccino just so I
could get a good one because my flight
was delayed right that's three
cappuccinos double shots in each and a
double shot espresso and then I get on
the plane and of course it's an
international flight so God knows you
know everybody else seems to know how to
live so they have a [__] cappuccino
machine
on there and I was trying to lay off
trying to lay off I was like what am I a
[__] [__]
I got a lay flat bed I'm not gonna order
a [__] cappuccino so I ordered
another cappuccino
and because I'm a ginger I just went it
doesn't affect me and I went right to
bed
went right to sleep in that lay flatbed
live flatbed whatever the [__] you call
it
and uh
landed in Toronto and I was actually
laughing just thinking to myself like ah
man these poor [__] bastards that get
addicted to caffeine and they get the
[__] headaches and they get the
withdrawals and all of that [__]
so when I was at the game the audit was
Senators game
somewhere about in the third period I
started getting a headache
and I was going oh [__] am I getting
sick what the [__] is this and then I
started thinking like I'll go wait a
minute
I go is this a caffeine withdrawal
headache and I looked it up I go how
long does it take
for a caffeine headache you know
withdrawal to come in that said 12 to 24
hours and it was literally 24 hours I
was like oh that's what it is and then I
had like all these negative thoughts
and I was all depressed and all of this
[__] I'm going what the [__] is this you
know am I just depressed because I'm on
the road I'm having a good time I went
to a hockey game what the [__] going
on it's laying in bed and the next
morning I woke up I felt fine I was like
oh
well there you go stupid you drink five
cappuccinos and a double espresso yeah
there's gonna be it's going to be a
price to pay why is this [__] couch
on wheels
I mean this whole thing I feel like I'm
out at Sea there's something about this
place
makes me feel like I'm on a ship oh they
got an old-timey clock radio here
this is very uh I feel like the stock
market's about ready to crash
anyway
let's do some [__] advertising reads
here shall we people
um oh look who it is everybody it's all
zip
recruit everybody you know if you were
to start a business
a new business what would it be
for example a taco truck business
uh a bouncy castle slash backyard
parties business why would you ever do
that oh my God
although snot-nosed kids jumping up and
down and then they bang heads and people
try to sue you
then you can't afford the air to blow it
back up again
an animal rescue shelter I love that
some kind of Charity some kind of
Charity somebody's gonna need something
selling handmade wood products
uh
uh whether you're starting a new one
selling handmade wood products what is a
the [__] 1800s whether you're
starting a new business or growing one
if you want to be successful you need
the most talented people on your team
that's where zip
uh quarter comes in and right now
you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com got your eye on one or
two people who'd be perfect for your job
zip there
um lets you send them a personal invite
so they're more likely to apply zip
also offers attention grabbing labels
that speak to job flexibility like
remote training provided
urgent two hammers given to you to bang
on a metal object outside of a hotel
room and more to really help your job
stand out let's yes
fill out all your roles with the right
candidates four to five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first [__] day
see for yourself go to this exclusive
web address to try for free
ziprecruiter.com
again that
zip.com slash Burr spell outbur b-u-r-r
sip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
oh Dakota is everybody indochi nope
look and Shop
all wedding season long shouldn't be
expensive with the custom fitted suit
from indochino you'll create a priceless
you'll create Priceless Memories without
costing a fortune that's great too
because what if you get divorced you
know more money in your pocket because
you got an indochino suit customize
every detail on your suit shirt dinner
jacket or more in a ring in a range of
colors from a traditional black or gray
to burgundy or Olive to a classic
Hemsworth Navy
how about a shout out for indochino that
they thought people would know what
Hemsworth Navy is
I got to get caught up on my uh
it just sounds like some waspy [__] to
me
they could be out playing Polo and like
know who the next president is going to
be sitting there near Hemsworth navy
suit every suit is made to your exact
measurement and you can customize every
detail create a suit that fits you and
your style perfectly with options for
fabric lapel shapes custom Monograms
statement Linings and more there's more
than what more do you need they also
have tuxedo start at five seven and nine
why rent when you can buy a custom tux
you can re-wear for years to come
especially especially if you're friends
with ahua who's going to get married a
whole bunch of times you don't have to
keep [__] you know just renting the
tux just get the 579 tuxedo right and
then you get in shape each time you know
so you make sure that it fits get a
superior wardrobe personalized to your
style and taste without the luxury price
tag explore their relaxed yet refined
approach to Spring suits with their new
spring Fabrics RS SVP knowing you've got
the perfect look look perfect look all
wedding season long from indochino go to
indochino.com
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com and use code bird
to get 10 off any purchase of 3.99 or
more one more time sing it with me
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code Burr
oh look who it is everybody hey
everybody look who it is it's game time
game time everybody buying tickets to
your favorite events shouldn't be
stressful game time is the fast and easy
way to buy tickets for all sports music
comedy and theater near you with killer
deals on last minute tickets and their
best price guaranteed oh it's perfect
the couple has a fight good [__] it I
don't want to go with you either that's
when game time swoops in and buys up
those tickets and passes the savings on
to you thank God there's heartbreak
across the other side of the city
because now you got mezzanine tickets
you can stop stressing over tickets and
start getting hyped for the fun you'll
have game time is the place for last
minute tickets uh the game time
guarantee means you'll always get the
best uh price if you find tickets in the
same section of row for Less hey game
time we'll credit your you 110 of the
diff 110 of the difference
that's some [__] confidence right
there it's the fastest growing ticketing
app in the country for a reason get
images of your seat before you buy so
you know exactly what to expect expect
when you arrive tickets are sent
directly to your phone so you never have
to dig through your email you don't have
to look at some [__] miserable
bastard on the other side of a ticket
window it just goes right to your phone
snag the tickets without the stress with
Game Time download the game time app
create an account and use code Burr for
twenty dollars off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem uh with code Burr to get twenty
dollars off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed
all right
I mentioned earlier that there was a
canal
that goes around Ottawa
and it didn't freeze over you know but
some stupid bastard [__] tried to
walk across it
you know and as we pulled up to the
venue there was like [__] four fire
trucks and three police cars I don't
know what happened
this person saw a little icy patch they
tried to cross it
and you know
seemed a little bit Overkill I mean how
many [__] fire trucks do you need to
fish one [__] fatty out of a goddamn
two-foot River
you know that's how much they care up in
Canada that that was America the guy'd
still be laying there
[Music]
doing a live Instagram
you guys this is just like typical okay
I'm still waiting for the first
responder hell I would settle for a
second responder at this point
um all right let me do uh let me do the
reach here at this point uh Bill great
emails okay let's see what we got here
[__] you from a reptile scientist
I was saying I don't like reptiles
uh yeah they're [__] frightening
just emotionless dear Billy boa
constrictor uh Monday's podcast you
spend eight minutes [__] talking
reptiles no I didn't
I said it was like 30 seconds there's no
[__] way I talked eight minutes about
reptiles that's pretty big talk coming
from a red hairy mammal [__]
uh reptiles are really cool they're over
300 million years old oh my God am I on
a tour in a zoo
Jesus Christ show us the gorillas
I don't give a [__] that it can change
colors and that its eyeballs can go in
two different directions
it's got enough poison to [__] kill
five elephants they're fantastic but is
it happy
oh look it's taking a sip of water this
is very rare
um anyway there are over 300 million
years old have lived with the dinosaurs
and will likely outlive Humanity so what
so will the Illuminati
doesn't mean I mean I wouldn't mind
seeing them in a cage if they exist
um they are personable
care for their young and exhibit complex
social structures and calls
well look at you breaking down
stereotypes they also provide valuable
ecosystem services such as eating pests
insects all right that's a big plus all
right maybe I was wrong build habitat
for other animals and can survive almost
totally freezing
also they haven't ruined the Earth like
humans have
oh Jesus Christ you didn't have to go
that far you have to go to humans you
could [__] say anything anything's
better than a human being at this point
you know what you had me with the
[__] mosquitoes and then you had to
you had to bring up the [__] you're a
human too you [__] scientist [__] so
[__] you you graduated cylinder anyway
you're you're [__] white lab coat
you've been living in your ego since you
got that [__] coat buddy and nobody
cares do you accidentally air quote
accidentally leave it on when you go
across the street for a cup of coffee so
everybody knows you're a scientist
you know
maybe if you had a heart you'd be
working with mammals
you [__] cold-blooded son of a [__]
um no you brought up a lot of good
points I have a newfound respect for
reptiles they still freak me out
you know
although when I went to Australia it was
a goal of mine to see a taipan
and I went to the zoo and I did see it
take a drink of water and everybody was
like oh it's gonna take a drink of water
um all right that's it [__] you and your
mammal mamleness P.S I saw you in
Chicago three years ago you were okay
best from Milwaukee
it probably was only okay
um okay okay all right okay baby all
right all right gun take
oh by the way here's a couple things I
[__] drive me nuts on the internet
inner internet the internet is every
time there's a video of a predator
killing prey and you watch the video
there always has to be some douche in
the contest because this is just nature
being nature
I mean I know this is hard for a lot of
you to want like they always like paint
themselves as they're the ones that can
handle
the harsh realities of life because they
can sit at home
you know and and watch some [__]
ferret get eaten by a goddamn Bobcat or
whatever the [__] happens out there
right
and you can sit there in your camo pants
with your dumb laptop you know with your
Ted Nugent sticker on it
[Laughter]
[__] sit there talking to me like I
don't understand this is nature being
nature
I love when human beings like see
something that is just something that
they could not deal with
on any shape or form without a [__]
weapon and then they have to take it
upon themselves to be the hero to
explain it to all the rest of us who
live in cities like do you you know you
just need to be in nature
and then there always has to be one
stupid [__] [__] be like oh I feel
bad for the deer and then they always be
like [__] you snowflake
how'd you enjoy your [__] Burger
today man with a [__] do you think that
came from it's just so [__] stupid
like somebody sent me something the
other day it was you know
Richard Nixon the dumbass records
himself right
and of course the tapes get out right
how funny is it that I'm literally
recording myself saying that he's a dumb
ass for a court well at least he see
Nixon was the original podcaster
I thought he was doing a show
um
so he was just going off on gay people
and he thought that Meathead
on All in the Family was gay and that
they were promoting the gay lifestyle
and that that destroys Society it was
just some wildly ignorant [__] and the
the I swear to God the [__]
the [__] people in the comments
section I mean the guy's not wrong
and I I read about [__]
I don't know 57 comments and they were
all saying this guy was a great
president and he's a hundred percent
right about homosexuality
he said that the reason why the Roman
Empire fell was because the lacks last
whatever six Emperors Were Gay it was
one of the dumbest things I've ever
heard in my life
um
and just watching all those people like
going yeah this guy's hitting the nail
right on the head
um unless they're Russian Bots it's like
I'm literally to the point if somebody
tells me they're a Democrat
or if they tell me that they're I'm a
Republican or whatever all I hear is I'm
a [__] [__]
um
yeah it was yeah it's it's not
it's not the Federal Reserve it's not
it's not corporations it's it's not it's
not not it's not political corruption
it's gay people
that's that's what ends
that's what ends Empires
you know if those last six you know
dictators were just out there [__]
broads you know the Roman Empire would
still exist I mean
I mean isn't that obvious to all you
guys it was so stupid as [__] I've ever
heard in my
I mean I get I get Nixon saying it
[__] 50 years ago I mean the guy
[__] grew up in a covered wagon for
Christ's sake
um it's like all right I get that but
the fact that like in 2023 people like
yup
that all tracks
uh
I would say yeah I would say the it's
it's a tie right now what's ruining up
my country is the the Federal Reserve
and the internet I would say those are
the two things
that are ruining it and uh
it's kind of weird how people are like
so accepting of the [__] internet and
all the [__] like beheading videos
and the [__] porn and all of this
[__]
it's just wild like how much they censor
everything else and the Internet is just
completely [__] wide open
and uh I really think it's like a big
experiment for all these governments to
just watch you and see where you
gravitate to so they can just spy on you
and build like a profile like all right
he you know he likes sports videos he
jerks off to this he likes cars all
right next person all right they're into
baking
yeah
like that paranoia you have to have
information like when I went through
customs up in Canada it's like I gave
them my passport the passport has a
[__] microchip in it and I get in the
passport he goes can you stand here so
we can take a picture of you it's like
why don't you just start building my
robot replacement in front of me but
I've just gotten to the point where I'm
just like you know
I'm at that age where like you know once
you have like your second colonoscopy
you just kind of become complicit
[Laughter]
it's like I don't have ass cancer I
don't give a [__] whatever I don't give
a [__] you want to make a robot me I get
it who gives a [__] all right gun take
hey Bill I'm a lifelong Democrat oh
Jesus he's a [__] [__]
um well back in the day maybe there was
some sort of
difference between the parties I don't
know if there ever was who knows uh hey
Bill I'm a lifelong Democrat albeit I'm
holding on to it by a thread
um pro-choice and I'm a gun owner
hey that's me
I'm not a gun owner but I don't I don't
mind people having guns
um
I just don't think idiots should be able
to get a [__] machine gun easily for
some reason people who
want to buy a machine gun I don't want
to have to [__] wait an extra line
so a school doesn't get shot up you
can't wait an extra week nope
and what if the tyrannical tyranny of
the government I need to defend myself
against that's another one it's like
dude that ship sailed somewhere around
World War II with the Weaponry that the
government has you're finished I don't
give a [__] how many guns you have some
nerd in Arizona will fly a [__] drone
to your house in Tennessee and wipe you
and your guns out before you even know
what the [__] happened
just this it is what it is I don't know
what I think we're just we're just at
this point we're going we're at terminal
velocity heading towards a [__] wall
uh I'm a gun owner I think you take last
you'll take last week was very measured
yeah it's called having respect for
people especially because I don't know
[__] about guns so I'm not going to
lecture people that have guns what I
would do is ask people that have guns
what they think the solution is but the
problem is is these [__] idiots on
the left always have to you know talk
down to Gun Owners which makes them
closed off [__] you [__] sick and
remember they do that [__] everybody's
just yelling [__] you with each other
sticking your lower jaw out
um anyway I'm more concerned with gun
protection than anything else it's
impossible for any government to keep
track of every gun and where it's going
getting guns illegally is actually
harder for the average disc disgruntled
postal person that it is for a lifelong
Criminal
all right I'm not the smartest guy I
gotta read that again getting guns
illegally is actually harder for the
average disgruntled postal person than
it is for a lifelong criminal okay
I would agree with that I would think I
would know where to get an illegal gun
um
I'm just a disgruntled comedian though
I'm Pro background checks as well I just
don't think the government should be in
charge of taking away guns
because clearly they abuse power
okay
I don't have a problem with that my
brother
in in way more conservative slash
libertarian than me and he can go for
hours about why background checks would
be an issue and despite the fact that he
makes some good points I'm sick of
seeing all these shootings and want to
see something happen well I was saying
like
for people that like those assault
weapons like
what would their what is their solution
like how do you make it harder
for that idiot that shot up the schools
because that person was a [__] idiot
with mental problems
I don't know anything about like the I
don't know I just looked at the person's
face I'm like you know if you just had
one hurdle I don't think that person
could clear it where if you were [__]
sane I think you could and you could you
could still get your weapon and that
other idiot wouldn't and then those kids
wouldn't be dead and you would have your
weapon and then what's the [__]
problem
um
I can tell you in aviation you know one
of the first things that the first time
they take you up or they're talking to
you they're not just talking to you
they're looking at you they're kind of
doing a little psychological breakdown
because you're going to be flying above
people's houses so they got to kind of
like look at you you know it's not the
most harsh thing but like
they had background checks with like
everything so I don't know anyway that's
probably a bad example as always
um it's away anyway uh what is where am
I here uh background checks play I'm
sick of all seeing all these shootings
and want to see something happen well I
would love it at these 24-hour news
networks would not make such giant
stories out of it to make money off of
the misery of these people and keep
giving these lunatics like this is their
way to get their face on TV before they
flame out of their miserable life
anyway it's a way it's way too easy to
get a machine gun people who live in the
country rightfully don't understand this
because it's usually suburb and City
people who lose their [__] uh I
appreciate you asking honest questions
and not being inflammatory despite the
fact that I don't agree with you on some
of the points you made
for all the younger listeners that's how
America used to be all right well that
was very Bill Clinton you didn't you
didn't you know it was nice what you
said
and you didn't answer my question
I was just uh
I was just asking a question oh look at
this Centrist [__]
oh this is the liberal the liberals who
who have a name for everybody who
doesn't agree with them Centrist [__]
Oh Billy both sides strikes again Jesus
[__] Christ stop trying to fool us
every week by trying
to and every man's thinking man
oh this guy was so Maddie he couldn't
even [__] stop trying to fool us
every week by trying
to and every man's thinking man to be
to be in every man's thinking man you
think picking a side is an issue because
you need to sell tickets in every Market
oh whoa they're building a whole
narrative here your level of cringe last
week was unbelievable
we this is like him speaking for
everybody we know what you're doing week
in and week out you can corroborate this
by reading the comment sections once in
a while well why would I do that
I don't give a [__] what you think
do you think I would get anywhere in
life if I actually read comments
all right here's one for people who
don't go around labeling everybody
um Centrist [__] oh geez who taught you
that word buddy who taught you Centrist
pick a side so I can either like you or
get mad because there's only two sides
in every argument it's like why not
[__]
it's it's just so it's so not adult
Behavior
like this guy said like first of all he
starts the subject of his email is
Centrist [__] okay and what's funny is
his goal is he wants me to hear what he
has to say so what does he do in the
beginning he insults me like how dumb is
that and then this guy wants me to read
comments by him and that that people
agree with him and like this is how dumb
you are
yeah you're listening you're not going
to get anywhere and nobody's getting
anywhere
um
just going around insulting people and
not trying to understand people okay
what I'm doing is not
um
just staying in the middle
what I'm doing is like actually
understanding that I don't have all the
information
I don't know [__] about guns and I know
that people on both sides don't want
what happened at that school to happen
okay but I'm smart enough to know that
walking around going hey you Centrist
[__] is not going to get us anywhere
all right and as far as like all of that
[__] about whatever the [__] you're
talking about this is how I sell tickets
on on the road buddy is I put out good
specials
that's all I focus on is trying to make
my special just a little bit better than
the last one sometimes I do it sometimes
I don't but I'm always trying that's
what I need to do not [__] picking a
side on gun control
all right
you non-centrist [__] okay
well you can see we didn't get anywhere
on that one all right big cats and movie
Wreck
Hey Oh Billy bombero
um my wife and I I actually think let me
go back to this guy what I think this
guy is actually doing
is uh he's completely avoiding
the question
that I asked I asked for a solution
from people that want to buy those guns
that's all I [__] asked and you
didn't do any of that and then you
attacked me called me some names and
then came up with some marketing scheme
that evidently I'm doing and evidently
everybody knows it oh my God everybody
knows it all right big cats in a movie
recommendation
hey Billy bombero my wife and I run some
camera traps AKA motion sensor cameras
in the jungle near our home in Costa
Rica
are you expats are you you you natives
down there and Allah and get a lot of
wild cat species passing by including
Pumas
ocelots and Margate gays
I don't know what those last two are
in eight years we've only gotten a
single jaguar and we hope to see it
again someday as they are such a badass
animal
and an indicator of truly wild places
dude that is one animal I would not want
to run into
um
Jaguars are [__] Mike Tyson in the
80s just unbeatable
I mean the fact that they go under the
water with the [__] alligator and
they come out Victorious
unreal anyway when you recently talked
about the otter versus the Jaguar fight
video we were cracking up at the way you
pronounce the word
jaguar and wanted to help you out
Jaguar
hermano there there's an R I'm from
Massachusetts I don't use those on the
end of the world am I supposed to say
jaguar like they say in the commercial
Jaguar
it's in there it just Trails off it's
easy goes down like a smooth Bourbon and
unless you're some Towny bar skank from
Revere you shouldn't be calling it a
[__] Jaguar
um well I am that that's
I am from that neck of the woods
I was more South Shore in American
English it's pronounced
I can't even say it's he's saying j a
dash g-w-a-r
aguar
yeah but you don't have which one do I
inflect
Jaguar
hey what's going on you want to take a
ride in my Jaguar
I feel like that white guy in the news
remember that sketch on SNL where they
would like get to the uh pronouncing the
uh the Latino City or whatever and they
would just go into this whole [__]
accent
um with the second syllable sounding
like the name of the band Gwar
but then to further confuse you
the Redcoats pronounce it Jaguar
as in Spanish it's pronounced Jaguar
but stick to Jaguar
and you're good to go I'm gonna say
jaguar
I'm gonna say it the way I say it if
there's a bunch of you guys are saying
all these different ways why can't I say
it the way I say it
all right
haguar
um also check out the 1982 movie The
Gray Fox which my Dad recently turned us
on to it stars Richard Farnsworth as an
Old Stagecoach robber who gets out of
prison and has decided and has to decide
what to do in a world that has changed
since he went in
it was such an awesome movie and we are
pretty sure you will love it all right I
will check that out I like how you spent
like [__] nine paragraphs ripping
apart the way I pronounced that [__]
word like any of that's gonna stick
all right I say it the way I said I'm
too I'm I'm too old to change all right
too old to change a new Netflix series
starring Billy red tits uh I've stuck
I've struck gold and don't know how to
proceed
hey Bill Nye the science Burr I'm a 22
year old software engineer working for a
defense contractor I was just accepted
to a theatrical computer science Masters
program at an Ivy League school
I don't even know what that is but Ivy
League school that's amazing my current
employer would pay for it but I need to
work full time while I did it likely
we'll be pushing 80 to 100 weeks
for the next two or three years oh 80 to
100 hour weeks for the next two to three
years truthfully unpetrified
I would love to enjoy my fleeting Youth
and travel date explore Etc I know
however that these types of
opportunities come up very rarely and I
should be Beyond grateful
dude I mean I can't even say jaguar
I don't know what to do with this
I mean I'm a meathead I just look I
don't want to [__] dude I don't walk
80 100 hours a week
what am I a [__] astronauts
[Music]
I don't want to do anything for 80 to
100 hours a week other than [__] sit
and stare at the wall
um I come from a very blue-collar
immigrant family so the fact I've made
it this far is America oh Jesus you got
the pressure of the family I would hate
to burn myself out in my early 20s how
do I strike a balance or is it better to
blast through the uncertainty and see
what happens
I thought a bald illiterate Ginger
comedian would be the best person to get
my advice from much love to you and your
family all right you got a sense of
humor I think I say you go for it
because you can always say you know what
this wasn't for me
and uh and then you you would have done
it and you wouldn't have any [__]
regret so
um
yeah give it a shot if this is what you
want to do I would give it a shot uh as
much as I'm sitting there going like I
don't want to do 80 to 100 hour weeks I
drove 80 to 100 [__] hours a week I
felt like when I was trying to make it
as a comic so you do have to make
sacrifices and whatnot
um
but don't do it at the price of your own
happiness that's what I would say
because as much as it was a grind to
make it as a comedian I did enjoy it and
it was an absolute thrill and there was
so many times no matter how bad the show
was like I couldn't believe that I was
actually a comedian at one point it kind
of hits you like uh I don't have a day
job anymore I am a comedian
I got to get some gigs and then
sometimes you get frustrated with the
business but then you step back like I'm
a [__] stand-up comedian I actually
you know can feed myself clothe myself
and pay my rent telling jokes that's
[__] amazing so
um if this is what you really want to do
I mean I don't think the 80 to 100 hours
a week will bug you
but if they do and you really don't like
it you know sometimes you try I try to
bunch of [__] out and then found out
that I didn't like it and then I ended
up finding what I did like so I would go
for it sounds like a hell of an
opportunity sounds like you want to do
it you don't sound like you get a good
sense of humor so I think that'll help
you out a lot and you can always pull
the rip cord if you don't
afterwards right why don't we just keep
saying the same thing [__] over and
over again sorry all right that's the
podcast go [__] yourselves and I'll
check in on you on Thursday